la ley electoral francesa prohíbe
publicar información de resultados
generales antes de que cierre la última
mesa electoral esta noche además prohíbe
a los candidatos expresar algún elemento
de polémica electoral también está
prohibido dar a conocer resultados
parciales como los que se pueden obtener
en algunos territorios de ultramar donde
las votaciones comenzaron ayer sábado
para evitar que los datos retrase en el
recuento final debido a la diferencia
horaria como en la polinesia francesa y
los departamentos y colectividades del
continente americano
quien incumpla este silencio electoral
tendrá una multa de 75 mil euros como lo
establece el consejo constitucional el
cierre de las urnas será a las 19 horas
sin embargo como se ha hecho en las
últimas elecciones con el fin de
facilitar el derecho al voto los centros
de votación de algunas ciudades tienen
la autonomía para extenderse hasta las
20 horas local sobre todo en las
ciudades más grandes en cuanto al
protocolo sanitario la ley no limita el
número de votantes que puedan estar
simultáneamente en un puesto de votación
sin embargo el presidente de esa mesa
electoral puede regular el acceso y
recordar al votante que respete los
gestos barrera teniendo en cuenta que el
uso de la máscara no es obligatorio y a
quienes la porten se les está pidiendo
que la retiren si resulta necesario para
verificar su identidad